ます
皆さんこんにちはか大法文学部の横山と申します
今日はあの観察の楽しさという切り口から
my first story を語りたいと思いますみなさんにお伝えしたいことは
ただ一つございます
視点が変われば世界が変わるそのことを終えの写真を使ってプレゼンいきたいとおもい
ます
どうぞ大きく
では話を始めたいと思います
私だと観察フィールドなんですが皆さんご存知の照国神社
このとなりそこは芝公園の一角になっておりましてちっちゃい声ですけど
探勝園という名前がついております
銅像が3体ほど経っておりますまあ観光地の一環ですからここにいらっしゃる人たちは
大概
銅像をご覧になるんですけども
私に言わせればこれは観光地の一環というよりもれっきとした
地球の一部であるわけですね
ですからここには様々な動植物が降りまして観察できます
まず観察を試したその1ですけど何かを見つける
この態度で臨むことが大事です
まず草花でいいます1年通じてきょっまあ約150種ぐらい
観察できます2月から5月にかけてさまざまなものが咲きます
例えばこれホトケノザ春馬なくさにもありますがあればちっちゃい子にあぁこうオニ
タビラコという種類になりましたこれとは別なんですが
そして私の好きなカタバミ色といい形と非常に可愛らしいってで皆さんはおそらくこう
いうものを見た場合に花だけを見ると思うんですねですけどあの実際は種類のにたもの
をたくさんありますですから
花をひっくり返して裏の額がどうなってるか葉っぱがどういう形がどういう付き方をし
ているかどんな風にこう
広がっていくそういう
の観察する必要があります乾燥するというのは目で見るだけではないんですね
アクションを
やっぱり買えないとなかなか見ることできませんちなみに私はこういうふうにしゃがん
でよくこの草花を見て写真を撮っておりますけどなかなか49歳には厳しい作業ですよ
ですけど好きだからやっております
ちなみに葉っぱ売りクアの裏返したりしますとね
そこにはめずらしい虫がいたりしてこれまたセレンディピティと言いますか
以上に面白い発見につながります
花が咲きバスト昆虫がやってきます
1年通じてこれもいろいろ見られますが
嬉しいことに去年も今年もですけどこのアオスジアゲハ
私の誕生日である4月5日に初めて目にすることできました
私にとって春を告げる長調でございます
そして今はシオカラトンボ大仕様から探訪も含めてたくさん
トンボも知っとんでおります
そして樹木ここにはまあ公園ですから8春くらいいろんな
君が観察できるんですが
まあ春になりまして2月以降まずは冬桜そしてこのヤブツバキがきれいに咲きます
そして山桜まあ普通の人達はあの桜花が終わっちゃうともう桜終わりみたいに思うと
思うんですが
この後サクランボみたいな実が付きます非常に面白いです
そして気があれば鳥が飛んできますこれも年間通じて30種類ぐらい
観察できますが
まご覧のよりアオサギのような大きな鳥からスズメ木のジョウビタキみたいな
ちっちゃい時までさまざまな鳥を観察でき非常にこれも興味深いです
観察お店したその2ですけどこういうものをいろいろ見てますと共通点
こういうこと木あの気がつくことをたくさんあります
例えばこれネジバナ
茎の部分がねじれております肌がこうねじりでつくんですね
これはまさに dna 閉じたような形じゃないかと非常に思います
そしてに来ては動物の神経系っていうのは10万分の二ミリの隙間ありまして
電気信号通れないんですねでそこは神経伝達物質をやりとりするんですけどそれは
まさにこの過ぎに代表されるようならッ植物が花粉を飛ばすそれに非常によく似ている
と思います
ちなみにこれ食べられない日はで犬日やつんですけど
女の子の乳首そっくりでございます
そして女の子の形マメ科の植物は大概この形を持っているんですね
分類上は蝶の形長兄というふうに分離するんですけどこれはこれで非常に綺麗です
さて樹木へ
花々と違いましてね1年通じていろんな変化を楽しむことできます
これは寒椿ですが春先になりますと紅りんごのコンポートみたいな
こういう葉っぱが鳴りますそして冬になりますとピンク白赤
まあ色とりどりの綺麗な花が咲きますそして冬がれた景色の中でこの茶色く
まあなったこの葉っぱですけど革製品のような非常にこれもこれはこれで綺麗な
あーものとして私は見ているんですがまあ皆さんもご覧ください
ここ8年くらい私このフィールドで観察していますが環境の変化ということを非常に
考えて感じます
それをまた観察の面白いところだと思うんですけどもまずこのし5年の変化で言います
とご覧のようなカエル
これ11月末村になりますと交尾の様子を盛んに見てましたが
a この数年の間にこれが非常に激減しましたそしてもうひとつは
皆様のお感じになっているかもしれませんがスズメ
意外とこれ見なくなりました
そう思ってましたら2010年の年末ですが鹿児島にどうか雪が降りまして皆さんご
存知だと思いますが
鹿児島においてはこれはもう怪奇現象って言っていいんじゃないかと思うんですね
そして翌2011年震災が起こった都市です1月にまず何が起こったかと言いますと
新燃岳が52年ぶりに噴火
そしてその2か月後に東日本大震災ですからおそらくこういうことはつながってるん
じゃないかと
非常に
岩田小思うんですね
でこれもまた観察のおもしろいところですけど命の営みを見つけると
去年は幸いなことにあの銅像の人一つのしたぐに丸い穴が開いておりましてここが
すすめのアパートになっておりました
で3月末から7月にかけましてすすめの子育ての様子を非常に詳しく観察することでき
ました
人間どうかあさんに負けず劣らずと言いますか
非常に子供の栄養を考えていろんなものをやは持ってくるんですね
非常に興味深く見ました左のほうが子供になります
さて最後に実験観察という観点でお話したいんですけども私は黒8年
あの桜もに一番あの力を入れてきましたものはこの野良猫研究ということになります
2008年度の話をいたしますえ私幸いなことに8匹の猫と仲良くなりました
でまず私何をやったかですけど人間が8人おりますと人間関係がありますよね
同じように猫にもやっぱりネコ関係というものがあるだろう
まあそれは小さいころからそう思ってましたそこでへ
2008年1月ですけどまず最初に行った調査ですがいったい何時に行くとここに8匹
の猫
すべているのかそれを調べましたところ朝は6時半前に行くと前いるということが
分かりました
ですから猫は早起きなんですね朝6時ぐらいに調査をすることにしました
猫関係を割り出すてがかりですけど皆さんと同じでございますみなさんは仲の良い人が
いれば必ず行動を共にします
一緒に食べる一緒に歩く一緒にね色んな事をすると思いますそれは猫も同じなんですね
で朝早く行くと前いる
ですから朝ごはんかないっていうのを考えました8匹いる
ら8つ食べるところを設定します
カリカリのエサですが八部切ると大体300g 食べるんですね
ですから1つ当たり37.5見れておりますそしてここでちょっと訓練をしました
な暮らしが集まってきますがちょっとまで
ちなみにあの猫を撮るときは普通のこのデジカメを渡し使っております
型落ちしますとは後にのされて叩き売りされるようなやつです
で
まあ猫にあの支障がないようにシャッター音を消したり
それからフラッシュは使わないようにしております
津波に鞄にはいつも猫餌を入れております
いつ会ってもいいようにです
猫立集まってきますがちょっとパペ
容姿っていうと一斉に席に着きますこのように
で最初に付いた1を基点として猫達はいろんな行動を取ります
食べ終わると帰っていくんですが時間にして20分これを50回やりました
4ヶ月半かかりました
このデータを使ってお話したいと思います例えば8匹の中にこの茶というおすすめ子茶
という名前にしましたがこのおすすめ子の特徴
横軸は自分を除く7匹です縦軸はペアになった回数
黄色は自分がこの茶が相手が食べてるところにアプローチした回数
ブルーは自分のところに食べてるところに i
手書きてくれた回数
つまり自分の家族
含めてこの猫の特徴ですけどすべての猫と仲がいいですね
持ちつ持たれつと言いますがそういう関係がありました
ですけどデータを比較しますとこの特徴を持っているのは茶と言う猫だけなんですね
ではどうして茶はこういう性格になったのかということが
まあお話したいことなんですが結論から言いますとこのちゃわー
非常に受け入れてくれる存在があったんですね一人はお母さんもう一人は強い
お姉ちゃん
ミート名付けた猫でございます
2001年当時と言います加工の茶は非常に雄でありながら情けなかったんですね
お姉ちゃんがこうにらみ合いになりますと
サッといなくなりますどうしてるか高はこんな感じで見てました
そしてよりによってまぁいろんなことがありましたが
11月に入りまして猫にとっては交尾の時期なんですが
よりによってその強いお姉ちゃんが安という猫にストーカー行為をされるようになり
ました
翌年の3月末迄これが激しかったんですね
私はすべて現場を押さえてますけども
ある日のことです
ヤスがお姉ちゃん名おかげでいきましたまず感動したことです
普段よとしてるこの手前によるお母さん猫なんですけど子供に何かがあると真っ先に
駆けつけるんですね非常に感動しました
次に感動した言あの様へは叱ったちゃんがですねこれを安に向かって
にゃにゃおっ
こう近寄っていったんですね時々私には猫の声が聞こえます
茶はこういったんですねめちゃいじめるな寝ちゃいじめるな
私の便はそう聞こえました
それでこっからまあ私の観覧ですが
茶はこの後人生初の行動をとるのではないかと思いまして
こっから先に週間茶を中心に観察しました
やってまいりましたこういう場面が
やっぱりやすっていう猫がお姉ちゃんにを変えていったんですねそしたら見てください
やめろ
出てきたんですね
やすという猫の首を見て下さい突然ちゃ勝手に出てきたので首が折れていると思います
しかもお姉ちゃんミーは自分を撃ってきたやつではなくて茶の方を見ていると
いまだかつてこんな勇ましい行動を見たことはありませんでした
この後どうするかおっかけていくんですね
みてくださいあのやすくんのお堂とした目尻尾和田恋とし
通した馬へすっかりそんな感じですよね
これはどうするか追いかけていきます
どうなって感じでしたよ
まあ非常に幸いなことになろうこの時現場には人間は私だけでございました
正直に感じたことを申します
お前は俺なんかよりもずっと男らしいと本当に思いましたよ
鹿児島大学教員学生含めて一番人以上男がいると思いますが
お前ほど男らしい奴は皆無だと思います
この後茶はどうするか年を越しましたやっぱり戦いは避けられなかったようですね
顔に傷を負ってしまいました
猫に限りませんが強い答えているのは照明きて戦います
理由はただ一つへたり逃げると多い家をかけられます後ろ足噛まれますそうすると獲物
を捕ることできなくなりますから命にかかわるんですね
傷を最小にするためには正面切って戦う
非常に答えはみんなそれを知っていますだから顔に怪我を負うんですね
シャワー顔にケガを負ったっていうのは基本的には強くなった象徴
まあこれこそ本当に名誉の負傷と言っていいんじゃないかと思います
ちなみに近くでご覧になるとはわかると思いますが私の半分花には激しい傷が2つあり
ますこれは酔っ払った挙句点灯してついた不名誉の傷でございます
その後の様子やっぱりやすとも仲良くするんですね
これがやっぱりちゃっていう猫の猫だなとすごく思いますが
2001年当時撮った写真で私好きなもの一番挙げろと言われればこの写真でござい
ます
昼間私この公園に行きますとれ今年はよく寝ておりましたが
チャーはいつも右側がお母さん左側なお姉ちゃんでございます
いつもこのメンバーで寝ておりました
茶はどうして成長できたのかそれは受け入れてくれるこの2人の存在があったからだと
私は思うんですね
それで
猫関係があるそしてそこには何かキーワードがある
それはこのことに尽きると思うんですね猫ってどういう猫にアプローチをかけるかと
いうと自分を受け入れて売ってくれる相手にアプローチするんですね受け入れてくれる
からこそアプローチをします
これは人間にも言えるんだと私は思うんですね
アプローチすることが大事なのではなくて accept することが大事
これはこれもですけど猫たちに教わったことでございます
非常にあの短い時間ですけど今皆今まで皆さんにねあのご覧入れた物っていうのは一番
1枚
もう本当に一期一会といいますかその時でないと目にできないことばっかりなんですが
本当に私にとってはこの一つ一つが my first story
ということでございますそれでこういう話を通じて皆さんに訴えたいことはただ一つ
見方をちょっと変えますと世界の捉え方確実に変わると思いますそしてそれは自分自身
の捉え方もまた変わると思うんですね
そしてこういうことをきっかけに私もですけどここにいらっしゃる皆さんも今後の未来
に対して何か良いきっかけになればいいのではないかということを願って
今日この場をお借りしてお
話をいたしました
以上でございますありがとうございました